[Music]
[Applause]
Dave mcmenamin is the ESPN reporter
covering the Lakers he was there with
game one last night in Golden State and
joins us on the program what did you
expect last night Dave
well the Lakers coming into it had 114
out of 18. they've been playing really
good ball in high leverage situations
they needed all those wins towards the
end of the regular season to secure spot
in the playing tournament
they beat Memphis their confidence was
spiked they got the weekend off so I
expected a strong performance I don't
know if I expected them to be up 14 in
the fourth quarter and kind of
controlling the action for most of the
night but their group that believes that
they can win this thing that was the
sense I had coming into it and certainly
they were going up to San Francisco with
the intention to at least get a split
the philosophy the offensive philosophy
Golden State took over 53s the Lakers
seemed like they were content aside from
LeBron to have two point attempts here
and get to the free throw line
does that philosophy change for either
team going into game two
I think the Lakers want to keep the same
diet I mean they have recognized that
they go generally as Anthony Davis goes
LeBron James is going to manage the game
however he deems fit on a night-to-night
basis based on however the defense is
playing but if Anthony Davis it's one of
those old maxims you feed the big man
and then it gets him more activated on
the defensive end he came off the series
against Memphis where he had 26 blocks
in a six game series he had four blocks
in game one and part of that was going
nine for ten from the field in the first
half just activating him as for the
Warriors obviously they were the highest
paced team in the first round of the
playoffs you're comfortable with Klay
Thompson and Steph Curry taking just
about any look they could possibly get
when they step on a basketball court
I don't know if I'm Steve Kerr perhaps I
I talked to Jordan fool a little bit
about some of the shots that he took but
overall I think both teams are content
with that stop I mean think about it's a
tied game with a few minutes to go okay
but if I paused the Jordan pool shot
as he releases it
would you have said good or bad decision
oh bad I'm like Steph Curry who's
leaning over in disbelief after the shot
Tara's off to the left now I have seen
and Tyrese Halliburton a bright young
star in today's game he defended the
shot he said what do you want it's less
than 10 seconds to go it's wide open you
want him to put her on the floor and
lose his you know vision and and the
separation there yeah right separation
but
you still have 10 seconds that's
sometimes a Maternity in a game and
considering how good that group is in
relocating uh Shooters look at the shot
that Steph Curry hit to tie it if that
was him zipping all around the court and
eventually getting open just beyond the
line on the right wing I think you find
a better shot yeah and I I commended the
Lakers for doing what I'm always telling
teams to do don't let the best guy on
the floor beat you they double team
Steph and therefore Jordan pool was so
open I don't know if he realized there
was 10 seconds left I don't know if he
realized exactly where he was on the
floor
but Steve Kerr said all the right things
after like all right you know we're good
with that you know like he has to back
up his guy but it it wasn't even a close
shot that that's what was alarming if
you just said oh man in and out or
almost when it it wasn't close
whatsoever and that's that difference of
26 feet to 30 feet and not a lot of guys
can do that with the game on the line
with the confidence to go I got my shot
I mean yeah we watched the finals last
year where he hit several shots even
beyond that Mark against Boston and so I
guess you could say he's done it before
but
every situation can generally find a
better shot especially considering his
teammates like you have Klay Thompson
you have Stephen Curry
I I think if you're gonna take that shot
you better make it
if you were going to bet on Anthony
Davis's performance in game two
really good or really average
there has to be a regression to the mean
based on what we saw in the first round
now it doesn't have to be Dave
well I mean to start nine for ten well
they have nobody to Guardian rebound
that is true I mean kavan Looney we
should put some respect on his name Dan
no he's good at rebounding when others
Miss he's just not good at maybe
stopping Anthony Davis
to me it was Anthony Davis getting the
shots to fall in the 12 to 14 foot range
his jump shot has eluded him for the
last several years and
that was assigned to me and again I had
a carryover at the free throw line which
is basically the same type of shot that
if he's gonna hit that they're not going
to be able to do anything with him uh
but just the Memphis series it was a
spike of a really good game
comes down to earth offensively but
still maintaining that defensive
presence I think the Lakers will take it
uh because if that happens you look at
the first round six games five different
leading scorers for the Lakers so maybe
you don't get a nine for 24 game out of
LeBron and he can carry you with the 30
plus Knight
Dave mcmenamin is covering the Lakers in
the Warriors ESPN NBA reporter we were
talking about this is not a rivalry
between these two franchises but it's
more of a legacy rivalry with Steph and
LeBron like if one wins another
championship like moving up the the
Legacy list there uh a title would be
more important to who in your opinion
between those two
if Steph gets a fifth ring on LeBron's
watch
there will be a lot of people out there
that that will have him Leap Frog LeBron
really
oh of course I mean we saw some people
last summer that was already put him in
the top five okay that fourth ring and I
think there will be a chorus of
that sentiment crescendoing whereas
LeBron's
place I think is kind of secure
so long as he keeps him away from him
keeps keeps it at a tie uh or certainly
obviously if LeBron gets a fifth ring um
LeBron is pretty much top of Mind a top
five player Steph would get there I
believe uh with the additional ring just
there's a recency biased on
understanding of that yeah because
LeBron has done it for 20 years Steph
has done it for 10 years
for you know 13 or something like that
at this point well he had a couple
nine-time All-Star is that right yeah
LeBron's a 20 time also yeah right 19.
yeah I mean listen I don't know if
there's any rationality like when it
comes to this conversation it's an
emotional one for a lot of fans but I
think to me if you zoom out a little bit
this is the two ambassadors of the MBA
changing
beneath their feet LeBron James is the
ultimate positionless player of this era
Steph Curry is the face of the
three-point Revolution both of those
tenets of the strategy
are are what now carries the day in the
league
you okay with him being winning MVP
I'm okay with it I voted for him last
year I voted for Giannis this year
I'm okay with it I I don't know it's a
little bit of a
you know so many times the broadmaid
you're finally the bride because you did
come in second two years in a row but uh
you just hope that he's as you mentioned
at the top of this segment you hope he's
on the court against the Celtics and can
look like the MVP in the biggest moment
of the Season yeah I think I think
Giannis is the best player in the game
uh but I and having voted on the MVP it
is weird though that we feel like oh
it's like the Academy Awards you know
it's that director's time or Scorsese
deserves it for that movie and you're
like is that the way we should vote that
it's embiid's time oh was it he missed a
lot of games
uh Fox had a better record yeah I know I
mean I know to me it was best player and
best team is kind of the thing that like
what I generally go to that's that's
what I begin with and then if someone
like totally uh
shoots that argument out of the water
then of course I'll evaluate their case
but yeah I thought last year was more
impressive for him dealing with the Ben
Simmons Saga and not letting that team
yeah fall from their expected level but
uh it it felt like there was a seismic
shift when uh Perkins mentioned about
the voting and the makeup of the voters
because you know DraftKings said the
Joker was a prohibitive favorite to win
and it's almost like the voters because
there wasn't much time left in the
regular season I don't think and it just
felt like maybe people did a reset on
that and I thought that that changed the
voting whether it changed it for embiid
winning but it felt at the time Joker
was the prohibitive favor to win the MVP
what kind of impact do you think that
had if any in your opinion
all right like Andrew Burke is someone
who I love working with and I hope
people listen to what he has to say
maybe not all the time but a lot of the
time
I think he is kind of has his pulse uh
or finger on the pulse of the things
that matter in the sport and
there was a time in the season when
Jason Tatum seemed like the guy was
gonna get it and you know even prior to
that Luca there was a conversation
around it it's a strange thing uh you
have to
have the requisite moments when people
are kind of locking in their vote and we
live in the 24 7 News cycle where
people kind of get bored of your case
even through an 82 Game season so it's
kind of having the moments at the right
time when people's minds are malleable
to come off the kind of the initial
front running narrative now I think
that's a part of it that is affecting
the ultimate outcome the votes are
public now
and if there is someone that it seems
like the PAC mentality is going with do
you want to be the one guy to step away
from that you know Mike Brown first
unanimous
Coach of the Year pick in NBA voting
history
I don't I mean I mean I voted for him as
well and I think he's well deserving but
I think a diversity of opinion is
sometimes a good thing and the fact that
all these awards are putting put out
there and people are concerned in some
level their mind about social media
backlash yeah doesn't help serve finding
the the most deserving players yeah you
know and I liken it to Patrick Mahomes
Giannis is in the Patrick Mahomes
category have we taken for granted you
know you want an MVP he won a title and
that's an ultimate compliment because
Mahomes is what 26 years of age maybe 27
and we're like
we forget how great he is and and I
think we did this with Jordan to a
certain degree certain players they
graduate and then we go oh that's right
and and therefore we root almost for the
new story to come up you know that we
can talk about this guy uh where you
know the media feels like they've been
desperate for Luca to be an MVP and I
keep saying he's not going to be an MVP
for a long time because the team is not
good
and it you know if he has the number one
seed then he can win an MVP but you know
he hasn't graduated there but it feels
like there's some of these guys who get
there you know when Jordan didn't win
twice with Barkley and Carl Malone
there's like people felt like the media
was desperate like give us another thing
to write about even though they were
worthy Jordan was still the MVP of the
league and to this day Dan LeBron has
four of them and within the last month I
was in the locker room post game with
him in Los Angeles and we're having a
conversation about something and that's
something gnawing at the back of his
mind and he brings it up
what's going on here's a crazy he hasn't
won one in 10 years Dave and this was
the first year of his career and now he
was not on my MVP ballot he missed too
much time the Lakers were under 500 for
a lot of the season first time in his
20-year career he didn't get one vote
for MVP that's a wild stat for 19
straight years people who whose opinions
quote unquote mattered viewed him as the
best player in the game were you ask him
about that
most likely yeah last night probably not
you know in the podium situation she's
sitting next to Anthony Davis but yeah
if there's a shoot around our practice I
think that would be an interesting
conversation hey thanks for getting up
with us we appreciate it uh thanks for
joining us Dave you got it done uh Dave
mcmenamin covering the Lakers Warriors
series ESPN NBA reporter